and as the southern border prepares for
a massive migrant surge secretary of
state anthony blinken homeland security
secretary alejandro mayorkas and
attorney general merrick garland all
traveling to mexico today to discuss
security issues bill mallusion is live
at the southern border with more this
morning hi bill
hi dana good morning to you one u.s
official who notably will not be making
that trip to mexico today is vice
president kamala harris who we all know
has been put in charge of this border
crisis which continues to get worse take
a look at this video we shot here last
night in roma texas we embedded with the
national guard out here the texas
national guard roma is one of the
busiest if not the busiest spots along
the border for cartel activity and human
smuggling activity the national guard
here has soldiers all over the place as
well as observation posts all over the
place they're keeping an eye out for
runners and human smugglers and within a
matter of minutes while the sun was
still up we started seeing rafts coming
across the river with those cartel human
smugglers bringing illegal immigrants
across the river texas national guard
was able to go down there and turn one
of those boats back but this is
something we were on the lookout for all
evening long national guard has a lot of
nice equipment they use night vision
they're able to scan the river excuse me
and look for anything that looks out of
sorts but eventually in the later night
hours we started seeing a constant
stream of these rafts and these human
smugglers and they were bringing across
hundreds of family units you'll see the
smugglers they weren't afraid one guy
was shirtless he was laughing making
jokes to us saying money money money he
was rubbing his fingers together making
the cash symbol these smugglers aren't
afraid they're bringing hundreds of
people over at a time and it's again
mostly these family units they were
being dumped out onto the shoreline by
the dozens uh we talked to one man he
told us he spent twelve thousand dollars
to bring over him his wife and his child
there was an unaccompanied girl only age
10 who came across
completely alone and then take a look at
these photos right here this is what was
on the shoreline as these boats were
coming across there were well over 100
people waiting to be across you can see
it with the thermal vision from the
national guard you can see a second
photo here they're able to watch these
guys during the night as they are coming
across the river and bringing their
human cargo over ask them why they're
not able to arrest them on the shoreline
they say it's a safety issue they're
worried the other smugglers will take it
out on the migrants potentially flip a
raft over and it'll turn into a rescue
operation for a bunch of little kids
take a look at this last piece of video
right here this was remarkable last
night we witnessed automatic gunfire
going from mexico directly into the
united states
the national guard soldiers we were with
you can hear them kind of reacting
saying whoa holy bleep
they say this is
suspected cartel gunfire going
indiscriminately directly into the
united states they said it was going
above one of their observation posts
kind of near the border wall but
incredibly rare to actually see direct
gunfire
from a machine gun going into the u.s
like that this was the second volley i
didn't get my phone out in time for the
first volley but pretty wild to see that
and to wrap it up here the national
guard soldiers told us multiple times in
recent days armed cartel members with
ak-47s have stood on the opposite side
of the rio grande from them and have
taunted them have racked the slides on
their guns and have yelled to them in
spanish that oh we should just shoot you
soldiers so tensions here along the rio
grande along the border obviously going
up and that cartel activity in the city
behind us um
it's still there we'll send it back to
you wow
bill that looked like tracer fire
and if the video is correct from left to
right that would be from south to north
as you described for the mexican side
what would they be firing at
don't know so in past days the soldiers
have told us there have been a ton of
cartel gun fights here in the city
behind us it's called ciudad miguel
aleman one of the most violent cities we
don't know if that gunfire was from a
mexican drug cartel shootout or if they
were just shooting across the border as
an intimidation factor above one of the
observation posts we don't know but
you're correct that was tracer gunfire
you can see the red tracers and
typically that's every few rounds is
when you see one of those tracers but
the soldiers told us they suspect it was
from an m240 machine gun or potentially
because the tracers were so slow it was
potentially a 50 caliber machine gun so
they don't know exactly but you can kind
of hear the reaction of the soldiers in
the background watching it with us they
were pretty shocked to see that it's a
remarkable report bill malugan back in
the border today thank you bill for that
careful what they wish for because they
might get a response i'm steve ducey i'm
brian killme and i'm ainsley earhart and
click here to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis